welcome back to kevin hart's the kelly
clarkson show
guess what this is a tribute to rad dad
oh my god with rad dads they are hi
give me some yes well kevin did actually
want to honor some amazing dads and that
absolutely describes my next guest he's
a single father of four boys
and this spring the family was
devastated when a fire tore through
their home
they lost everything they're now living
out of a motel
and here to talk about it is troy so say
hi to kevin troy hi kevin
hey what's going on man that much not
much he's like just hanging out
um well why don't you start this off
since you're you know troy i mean look
first of all welcome
to the kevin hart's the kelly clarkson
show it's a tribute to rad dance
man guess what you fit the mold sir
which is why we're talking to you
how's everybody doing yeah everybody's
safe and that's the
biggest thing of that yeah that's a
major blessing um
so before we get to that you already had
a tough year as a family right
oh yeah we've we've been devastated you
know the um
i was doing um home theaters custom home
theaters and co would hit
and i lost my job went on unemployment
then the distance schooling
happened and we're all at home
and i think just the stress of income
and my kids not going to regular school
i think all that stress i end up having
back to back heart attacks
and i think somebody up there is wanting
me
to stick around for my boys because you
know i'm all they have
man i can't too back to back that's a
lot of stress on on not only you but
your boys as well so
can you tell us how did the fire start
do you know um
i found out later it was an electrical
panel faulty electrical panel
that's what the fire chief said fire
marshal or somebody
wow so what do you want do you want to
ask anything kevin uh well you know i
mean the one thing that you just said
that was really amazing man you said
you're a walking miracle
uh i think that's not only correct but
that's an amazing thing
for you to understand and realize are
you taking that energy that you now have
and are you putting it all into your
kids at this point
yeah i mean right now i'm i'm in limbo
right now because we're living in a
single room motel so
i'm doing everything i possibly can
still
healing from my heart attack but i take
the kids to the parks they take them
swimming i try to because you know being
confined in a motel all the time is
really trying on these poor kids you
know
so i'm still doing the best i can in the
situation
that i'm in i mean that's got to be
incredibly difficult too because we just
saw the picture of your boys and their
ages they're in school so they've
obviously been doing online school
probably as well right
yeah distance learning we um now that
we're doing it in a motel room it's it's
it's really trying i got somebody in the
bathroom somebody in the closet
somebody on the bed you know maybe
somebody's out in the car trying to do
their distance learning it's
it's really hard right now we're in
we're in a bad situation
it's horrible yeah well can you tell us
more about your boys they seem
pretty resilient with you um or so i've
heard my oldest he's kind of my
genius nerdy scientist he's always
coming up with something new
i got my 11 year old steven he's
autistic
and he's like we're just so smart in
school he's like the top of his class in
math and uh in reading and then
then i have max who is my caregiver make
sure i take my medication
he's always cleaning he's always got to
be matching clothes
and then my my youngest seven-year-old
he's he's my little tasmanian devil he's
always off the hook always wants to be
the ham
dancing for anybody i mean they're all
they all got their own personality also
with us
is troy a single father of four boys who
is
currently homeless after a devastating
house fire his boys charles stephen max
and leo are also with us welcome you
guys
i like that blue shirt oh y'all look so
what's up fellas
how you doing all right all right well
let me ask y'all something has the
community really stepped up to help i i
heard they have
the community here in vallejo is is so
amazing i've had people come to my hotel
room
bring us home-cooked meals bring us
brand new clothing for me and my
children
and some of these people didn't look
like they had the money to even give
and that's the most touching thing of
this whole community is it's been
wonderful
wow well you want to take it from here
yeah man uh first of all that's an
amazing looking family that you have man
a bunch of handsome boys that i see guys
uh
you know i think that you should be
so lucky so lucky to truly
understand what this moment is about
right now and it's about your dad just
being so brave
so tough to stand in what he's standing
in and realize that
he's not only doing it for you guys but
he's doing it for himself
and i love that like you guys right now
have just kind of amplified my energy
and just
putting a warmer feeling and spirit in
my heart and i don't know if you noticed
or not
but today this is kevin hart's the kelly
clarkson show
so you know for me hosting on like my
first big day here
this is a bigger moment for me like and
i'm gonna give you guys something
that never happens i'm gonna give you a
little bit of my drums
can we hit him with one real quick
please hit him with one
yeah something man he doesn't get that i
want to change the light move man
because right now it's amplified a
little more
these boys got my energy and my blood
boiling correctly yeah another color if
you can what's y'all's favorite color
what's somebody's favorite color there
blue blue
blue let's go back to the electric blue
back to electric blue for the board
do it yeah blue is my favorite back to
the electric blue with the boys
so and it's so sweet that y'all really
are understanding i was i was just
you know listening to even my producers
that i was talking to before the show
it's really important like kevin said
everybody's understanding this is a hard
moment for your family right now
but the people that are going to get you
through it are sitting right next to to
each other it's y'all
and and that's why we also reached out
to arcade one up the leader
in at home entertainment and creator of
the retro arcade games
like pac-man and mortal kombat and
pinball machines featuring star wars
marvel superheroes and attack from mars
they think that you are a super dad all
right and so
they're gonna give you 40 thousand
dollars and i'm going to round it up to
an even fifty thousand
oh my god yeah that's fifty thousand
dollars guys you know what
hit kelly winning one time
[Applause]
and just so you know i know like the
guys right now are like okay cool that's
money and dad's probably more excited
about that but that's not all
actually arcade one up wants you and the
boys to have some fun
as well so they're also giving you a
classic video game machine
of your choice you can pick
[Applause]
[Laughter]
well thank you guys so much you're
you're a beautiful your beautiful story
and thank you for joining us
thank you for having us it's a blessing
oh man absolutely
hey wait a second guys i didn't leave
yet kelly do you mind
no not at all just i don't know the way
where you can kind of yeah just i'll
just be over here thank you
uh real quick detroit and his kids man i
can't get out of here without giving you
guys something
so i'll match what they gave all right
you got 50 coming from kevin hart
himself as well
you guys i want to see you guys happy i
want to see you guys with your spirits
up
that goes to you hey i'm in a good mood
for the rest of the world put yourself
in a good mood
go watch fatherhood it's on netflix
right now
[Applause]
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure